(whooshing)
- [Narrator] "Faith is
taking the first step
"even when you don't see
the whole staircase."
Martin Luther King, Jr.
On August 23rd, 1963,
(inspirational music)
a quarter of a million people
went to Washington D.C.
to hear Martin Luther King, Jr.
speak at the Lincoln Memorial.
How did he get so many people to come out?
He didn't have a newsletter
or a Twitter account,
he wasn't making YouTube videos
or using Google AdWords,
he didn't have a website
or use Facebook.
He didn't have any of the tools
that make it so easy for us today
to reach people and start movements,
and yet 250,000 people came out.
Why?
Because he stood for something important.
The cause he believed in
touched people's hearts
and led them to action.
It was so important that people willingly
spread the word and promoted his cause
because it was their cause.
You need to do the same.
What does this have to do with business?
You might be thinking, "That's great,
"it works in political
or cultural movements,
"but what does it have
to do with business?"
I'm glad you asked.
What we're talking about
here is getting people
to take action,
influencing decision making
by appealing to something that people
feel passionate about.
It can apply to going to your website
and buying your product
just as easily as it does
to getting in a bus and traveling to hear
Martin Luther King, Jr. speak.
Most companies just never do it.
Your business is not just about
making a product or service.
That's a recipe for failure.
People want to know who you are
and what you stand for before they'll
buy anything from you.
It's about standing
for something important
and having your cause be
your customer's cause.
(whooshing)